BEEN A GOAL.
>> THESE TWO TEAMSS TO GET THIS.
IT'S NYQUIST TO START THEE THEY
WERE UNDER FULL CONTROL HERE.E.
JACKETS WIN ANOTHER DEFENSIVE
BATTLE AND THEN
THE BATTLE ENDS CONCERNED
BUT EICHEL LAST-MINUTE GOT
REALLY STRONG ON HIS STICK GETSD
AND HERE'S EICHEL AFTER TAKING
THAT PUCK FROM ROSLOVIC, A
DOMI, DENIED.
A
SILLINGER GOAL.
HE PICKED UT UP AN ASSIST OTHE
POWER PLAY.
>> IT COULD HAVE BEEN AFTER THE
REFS WERE IN HE THREW TRYING
TO STAY ALEUIVE.
GET THE
PIECE OF IT OR NOT, BUT
BJORKSTRAND HAS BEEN  RBLG. FEWD
TONIGHT HE COMES IN, HE GETS TOY
DISCOMBOBULATED HERE, THE
JACKETS ARE JUST ALL LINE CHANGE
FOR THE BLUE JACKETS, AS THE
OUT OF THE ZONE.
DROP PASS ICE, EICHEL GETS IT RT
THERE TO STEVENSONT.
CARRIER.
CAREENS THROUGH AND ACROSS THE
LINE, MOVING NYQUIST WAS
IMPEDED.
>> HE GOT THE BACK OF HIS PANTSE
NET.
HE'LL PLAY IT OUT INTO THEHEY S.
THEY FOUGHTA BE PATIENT W